could we do to improve k-12 education in
America the best well today it's if
you're motivated to learn if you really
really really want to learn this is an
amazing time for everyone because if you
have access to Wikipedia if you have
access to the latest information on the
web there's a new website that I've just
been using my kids recently called Khan
Academy KHN just one guy doing some
unbelievable 15 minute tutorials there's
great college lectures out on academic
growth org so if you're motivated now
you can go to the very best lectures
speaking of allocation of society's
resources I think you said it on your
campus tour at least at Harvard that the
allocation of IQ points of our society
to Wall Street financial instruments was
higher than it needed to be and that
some of those IQ points should go into
other fields yeah well if you say okay
what portion of society's IQ goes into
studying great teachers and documenting
what those great teachers do and how you
would spread those practices you know
what is effectively the R&D component in
education it's about as close to nil as
you you can imagine in yet what's the
most important thing in terms of having
a society that has both got equality of
opportunity and is competitive with
other countries it's education and so
it's it's this mind-blowing this
allocation you know my favorite vignette
is that guy of Salman Khan he was a
hedge fund guy making lots of money and
he quit to do these little web videos
and so we've moved I'd say about 160 IQ
points from the head fund category into
the teaching many many people in the
leveraged way category so you know that
was like that was a good day the day
that his wife let him quit his job now
we need something like that you know in
a very broad and dramatic way